during the 90s collectors began
appreciating the charms of vintage
travel art and over the past two years
dealers say the genre has exploded even
more bloomberg pursuits as chris rosar
joined madison mills and scarlet foo to
dive into what's behind the trend this
is presented by american express
for many of us it's been almost two
years painful two years since we've
traveled to far away places and
collectors are cashing in on this
through travel related art
exactly and dealers say the market is
steadily growing but lockdown has been
exceptionally good for business so
bloomberg pursuits editor chris rouser
is here with us to discuss this and this
week's now boarding chris always great
to speak with you
i knew nothing about the vintage poster
travel business before this segment so
tell me what this whole industry is
about so uh vintage travel posters were
actually just travel posters became a
thing around the turn of the century
when uh travel companies like trains
hotels cruise liners started trying to
market to middle class travelers and
encouraging people to travel for leisure
so not just you have to get from point a
to point b or you have to go to uh to a
retreat or see family but maybe you just
want to get on the train for fun and
they started making these beautiful
posters uh many an art deco style with
these incredible artists many french to
sort of entice you into trying new
things and it really worked well these
examples definitely get me sold on
putting a lot of these in my apartment
but it's a very costly hobby i want to
pull up one example we've got a poster
of santa fe that's estimated to be from
eight thousand to twelve thousand
dollars um and another one of new york
that's estimated to be two thousand to
three thousand dollars that's the one
you're seeing on the right there um what
exactly makes these so valuable in some
cases it's the rarity so these uh
posters were actually published mostly
on newsprint they're almost like those
signs you see sort of pasted up on
construction sites in new york they were
very low quality in terms of materials
and so very few of them actually exist
so if you have
one of those that's in good condition
that's a destination that people might
really want to buy for themselves like
new york for example those ones are
going to be more expensive and although
i will say they are expensive they're in
the thousands of dollars that's pretty
cheap uh for you know fine art so it's
actually something that a lot of more
people can afford okay so it's more
accessible to people um something you
said that that really i thought was
funny was getting on the train for fun
it's something that we don't do
during the pandemic era so what exactly
was the impact of the pandemic on this
market for vintage travel posters so
they've been rising in popularity since
the 1990s they've becoming more cool and
stuff and americans and europeans have
been collecting them but over the past
18 months they have skyrocketed in
popularity and and that has pushed up
their values because people have been
trapped at home and they want to look at
their walls and they want to imagine
there's some place there someplace else
maybe in college you saw on your
friend's dorm room walls like a french
cafe poster it's the same kind of art
and now over the most recent years
travel posters have become that kind of
hot thing chris browser thank you so
much for joining us in this week's now
boarding
interesting i guess if you can't go
there posters are the next best thing
all right thanks for tuning here into
quick take i'm jennifer zabasanja in new
york we'll have more quick take coming
up in a few